who for anyone who wants to get into the
filmmaking business right now
what are some of the essential pieces of
equipment they need to have in terms of
the camera computer and editing system
what would you advise that people
purchase I think that's the great thing
about getting into filmmaking right now
is that you need so little you know
really you can do it yourself you know
with a DSLR with a laptop with you know
it used to be final cut but now I would
say premier or I guess if you're
learning now when you final cut 10 is
great actually but that you know I think
people filmmakers these days don't know
how good they have it and of course the
generation before me was probably saying
that about me
but essentially it's so it's so much
easier now to get a passively
good-looking image you know with the
shallow depth of field you have a large
sensor camera that it looks like a movie
when you go shoot something for very
little now and that wasn't the case
until a few years ago with the explosion
of DSLRs so it's a great time to be
making movies with very little money as
far as getting your foot in the door and
you know making something that resembles
a movie when I was in school we were
shooting on VHS cameras so no matter how
good your writing no matter how good
you're directing at the end of the day
it was going to be terrible so it's nice
to be able to go make something with the
tools that are out there for very little
now that and you actually have it you
know look and sound good any advice on
staying ahead of the curve it seems like
so many things are wonderful there's so
many wonderful products and they do look
like film but then they're obsolete in
two to three four or five years is that
just the nature of the beast or there's
certain things that you can purchase
that will kind of keep you ahead of the
curve that won't be as obsolete in the
next few years I just think it's a
filmmaker you can't get caught up and
worrying about being on the latest
version of whatever is out there you
know we cover those things onto a film
school and it's great to check in and
know what you know what's what the
latest greatest tool is but ultimately
these storytelling is timeless and you
know
it it's a very rare situation that your
camera or your equipment is gonna be the
thing that makes or breaks your film
someone said once that like part of
being a filmmaker is what do they say
gear addiction mm-hmm that you get this
sort of gear acquisition addiction and
and it's just part of you just know that
your bank accounts going to take a hit
and it's just part of the thing is that
is that something that you have to
accept being in this business or having
this hobby you know gear addiction is
something it's something that I've
suffered myself I'm a gear addict hello
my name is Ryan but you know it's one of
those things where I think it also
demonstrates your commitment to your
craft and for me ever since I was in
high school there could have been a
situation where I'd buy a nice
fill-in-the-blank you know or are you
gonna go buy a car are you gonna go do
this and for me I was always spending
money on gear because I believed in
myself and I believe from the stories I
wanted to tell and the nice thing of
course is that the gear you buy now may
be obsolete but you can still sell it
and so as you're sort of building up
these tools that you have in your
wheelhouse I think that you know you can
view the addiction is a bad thing but
it's not bad to the best in yourself and
that's essentially what I think buying
these tools represents in terms of
research as to which brand or whatever
someone needs to do for the various
products they want to buy how much do
you spend I know things are different
because you're running a website
dedicated to looking that up but how
much time would you say the average
person should dedicate to looking up the
different reviews and things like that
on different products we say how much
time or how much money that you spend on
these things or a little bit of both but
yeah how much sort of due diligence
should you do in researching what brand
versus Canon Nikon whatever the way I
view it is I spend most of my time
working on at this point screenwriting
you know a few months ago it was
directing when I are editing
on what stage on that with various
projects but when I'm surfing the web or
if I were somebody reading no film
school if I weren't writing and managing
the film school I was reading these
things I see that time as something that
you're doing instead of watching
football on Sunday to me it's not an
exclusive and mutually exclusive thing
it's like I'm on this website and I'm
reading about these things because I
care about it and quite frankly I think
a lot of people do these things while
they're at a day job they don't want to
be at so you know I'm reading and
researching materials not instead of
working on a screenplay but in addition
to it and I think on the money side of
the equation there are a lot of ways
that you can invest in equipment that
don't require you to have a lot of money
yourself you know one is are there loans
is there financing you can get I know
that when I bought a red camera I went
and applied for a credit card that had
0% interest for 21 months so I paid it
off it was like $300 a month for the
next two years essentially but I didn't
have the money in my account at the time
when I went to buy it and then I sub
rented it through a rental house so that
it was generating income on its own so
you know I think some people saw an
article on route that said I was buying
a read and they assumed that you know I
had a lot of money in my bank account
and why was I is an indie filmmaker
spending money on a camera instead of
the film itself when actually that
camera basically ended up costing me
nothing because I put it on the car and
I paid it off their sub rentals so I
think you have to be savvy as a
businessman when you're investing this
equipment and then if you're not
supplementing it like I have think about
what kind of income its generating for
you whether you're on a production
company or whether you're a DP can it
add to your day rate and just making
those calculations it's something that
can you know it should be paying you not
vice-versa
wow that's a great point yeah so so
using credit cards but using it in a
smart way where you know you could avoid
the the finance charge and in terms of
how much research did you do before you
decided on that was the camera that you
wanted and again it's different because
you know you're the head of no film
school so I get that but in terms of
like someone else that maybe
isn't doing that it doesn't run a
website how much do you think they
should devote to researching you know I
think it's not as I said that's not
gonna make or break your projects I
think there's not there's no such thing
as the best camera there's only the best
tool for the jobs that you do and
depending on whether you shoot
documentaries whether you shoot weddings
whether you shoot features you know all
those things are going to be different
but ultimately we're great it's great to
be a filmmaker now because the tools are
so good and they work in you know
various lighting conditions they can
shoot different frame rates they have
audio inputs the you know the DSLRs
would be hacked to do raw video it's you
know it's an amazing time to be a
filmmaker and I wouldn't worry about
well I have this camera and he has that
camera there for his movies gonna look
better or worse it's not really gonna be
that they make a breakpoint I think
you